ja ich komme heute mit der frohen
weihnachtsbotschaft sich der frauen
drohen weihnachtsbotschaft als ausklang
des weihnachts engels fürchtet euch
nicht fürchtet euch nicht
das sagt uns der weihnachtsengel und ich
muss sagen er war nicht ganz präzise
nämlich will sagen furcht ist etwas
gesundes denn vorsicht ist es dass
präzises furcht überredet einem zu
vorsicht ist immer etwas konkretes
gerichtet aber was in den letzten
monaten und jahren zwei jahren erlebt
haben ist eine angst rhetorik und wozu
angst führt sehen wir in den letzten in
den letzten wochen ganz klar angst holt
das schlechteste aus den menschen heraus
was angst wird es ist das ist die
menschen ja fast böse macht ich immer
angst ist etwas diffus und diese monate
der monatelange angst rhetorik hat eben
gezeigt dass wir gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden wenn
altbundespräsident gau alle ungeimpften
pauschal als bekloppte beschimpft dann
ist das für mich spalterisch die neue
regierung hat in ihr hat in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag folgenden satz
geschrieben wir wollen eine kultur des
respekts befördern ich würde mehr als
weihnachtsgeschenk vielleicht erbarmt
sich jemand von ihnen ich wünsche mir
ein t shirt auf dem steht artikel 1 des
grundgesetzes die
menschenwürde ist die birne des menschen
ist unantastbar und dann klein darunter
das gilt unabhängig von ihrem impfstatus
alexander ich würde spricht ein ganz
ganz wichtigen punkt an gerade zu
weihnachten gerade bei der frage wie wir
mit umgehenden umgehen ich fand vor
allem die debatte in den kirchen so
absurd ich war in der jugend
kirchenorganist und war jeden
sonntagabend sollte morgen sozusagen der
kirche und habe mit musik begleitet wenn
ich mir vorstelle dass dort künftig
ungeimpfte nicht mehr rein dürfen weil
man sagt ja nur noch geimpft geht nicht
anders dann frage ich mich auch was
eigentlich in unserer gesellschaft
passiert ist also es ist wirklich so
absurd geworden teilweise und
gleichzeitig wundere ich mich wundere
mich über deutschland auch über die welt
dass wir das alles überhaupt noch
aufhalten also natürlich gibt es eine
spaltung die die durch das land
mittlerweile geht aber gleichzeitig gibt
es auch keine spaltung das stimmt also
durch das ist keine spur gibt sondern
dass uns das sagt und ich hab so ein
bisschen das gefühl dass deine uhr tickt
war lange kann das sich mit der conti
coachen möchte ein hake ich finde diesen
satz von scholz eine verächtlichmachung
der menschen die gegen die dagegen
aufstehen zu behaupten wäre in münchen
sind vor zwei tagen 35.000 leute auf die
straße gegangen das war nicht irgendwie
irgendwelche rechtsradikalen dass man
ganz normale menschen in münchen auf die
schnelle und bürgerliche menschen mehr
auf die straße gegangen sind zu sagen
dieses land ist nicht gespalten ist fast
noch das unverschämte weil es eigentlich
eine es ist so entschuldigung echtes
wenn ich den vergleich sei es ist so wie
der ddr czk richter steht es gibt gar
keine demonstrationen
alex ist dann eine zeit total
interessant mit der habe ich heute auch
lars klingbeil konfrontiert anfang der
woche gab es nurmehr ish mehr ungeimpfte
als menschen die urlaubs krank
angerempelt haben ja also dann von einer
besonderen minderheit zu sprechen ist
schon erstaunlich oder absolut absolut
und ich möchte noch mal zurückkommen
diese nicht nur nicht mit uns geht die
spaltung dieser gesellschaft die wir
miteinander umgehen sondern ich glaube
auch stellt man sich jetzt mal vor eine
ungeimpfte familie ein vater geht mit
seinem kind spazieren der vater hat
vielleicht angst vor der impfung also
angst ist irrational vielleicht hat er
bei der ersten impfung zu viele
nebenwirkungen gehabt und lässt sich
dann nicht noch mal impfen gilt damit
mit einer impfung kennst du ja als
ungeimpft geht spazieren gehen die
einkaufsmeile entlang und dann sagt das
kind macht sich aber schön blass uns da
reingehen und dann sagt der vater sein
kind wir dürfen nicht und ich glaub da
oder tun gehabt aber ich darf nicht oder
soja
da verlierst du so ein urvertrauen in
den innenstadt wenn der staat die ihr
verbietet sebastian überhöhung die wurde
heute von der firma acht zuschauern
geschrieben wir freuen uns sehr über
ihre briefe und jetzt geschrieben sie
hatte schuhe abgegeben vor der zweig
also bevor es eingeführt wurde schuhe
zum reparieren stiefel für den winter
kenne ich auch da wollte sie gestern
april mit ihrer tochter die zwölf ist
standen sie zusammen da haben den
schluss darum die schuhe gebeten weil
ich gesagt impfausweis bitte das waren
so untergeschoss kennt man doch in den
bahnhof also ehrlich gesagt da ist jetzt
auch kein geschlossener raum und dann
hat er gesagt ich kann ihnen die schule
nicht rausgeben weil sie nicht geimpft
und sie hat richtig in seinem blick wohl
gesehen dass er dass das eigentlich auch
gut fand so als ich gefragt ob ich kann
meine tochter dann kommen so hat er
gesagt nein das müssen sie selber tun
sie können sicher impfen lassen und dann
kriegen sie ihre schuhe da muss ich
wirklich sagen erst mal wieder nicht und
wir ausstellt vor die tür bringt das man
nicht irgendwas macht das hat ja nichts
mit dem infektionsschutz geschehen zu
tun und ich fand das ganz großartig wie
du gesagt hast das macht was mit den
kindern und das glaube ich auch fehler
als politischer beobachter was glaubst
du für das für konsequenzen haben
möglicherweise auch für die politische
landschaft in deutschland bislang muss
man ja eins sagen die afg konnte nicht
besonders profitieren von der korona
politik also die querdenker entwicklung
hat sich jetzt noch nicht auf das
wählerpotenzial der after
niedergeschlagen ja das zeigt eben dass
das keine radikalen sind die menschen
diese haltung haben so eine ganz normale
wie wir auch aus den demonstrationen
wissen sondern dass die wirklich zum
teil einfach diese einstellung haben da
kann man gegen sein ich sage auch ich
bin für diese impfpflicht trotzdem
respektiere ich bin jemand sagt ich will
mich nicht impfen lassen das ist ja das
gericht alle jetzt flächendeckend quasi
diese zweig regelungen zum kippen
bringen und sagen das gilt nicht aber
dass lena gesagt hat wie auch ein punkt
das ist beobachte ich auch zum teil
bringt diese haltung in einigen menschen
das schlechteste hervor da wird jeder
zum hilfssheriff jetzt und ich habe ja
auch in zügen beobachtet mal also wie
man da gemaßregelt wird manchmal wenn
einmal die maske verrostet ist manchmal
unter aller kanone nicht und das sollte
nicht sein wir sollten trotzdem es gibt
immer das schöne wort des respekt ist da
auch respektvoll mit der meinung der
anderen art umgehen auch mit der meinung
von impfgegnern und die politik muss man
schon sagen die haben ja diese
überprüfung abgewälzt an leute die
eigentlich nichts dafür kann jeder
restaurant kellner muss sich fragen sind
sie geimpft oder nicht gibt was die
aushalten müssen was leute von einem
geschäft aushalten müssen wenn sie sagen
tut mir leid zweig regelungen kommen
hier nicht rein also da wurde es dann
schon auf die falschen abgewälzt diese
konsequenzen diese diese konflikte die
die gesellschaft mittlerweile hat in
sich zu tragen und was mich ehrlich
würde besonders ärgerliches oft immer
der satz kommt wir haben es ja mit
freiwilligkeit probiert er hatte kein
einsehen also müssen wir jetzt zwingen
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an
bananenrepubliken bereit waren sowieso
so symbolische kandidaten aufstellt und
dann am ende wird dann doch der kandidat
von dem man sich vorher
schon so freiheit ist immer die freiheit
der anderen und in diesem fall ist
freiheit auch diejenigen nicht nur der
impfgegner sind das auch aber direkt die
konsequenzen tragen